- Who's stacking the cups?
Don't stack the cups!
Can we just keep water in here,
and then just drink our side-beers?
Rinse your ball! Rinse your ball!
You should have a water cup and Purell.
Oh, that wouldn't have counted anyway
because you didn't wash your ball before.
Wash you ball!
Are you trying to take us down
through biological warfare,
is that what you're doing?
Trying to get us sick over here?
Because you need to wash your damn balls!
- You ain't got this.
Alright.
Fade away.
Game. Set. Match, blouses.
If I make em all, you know what I mean,
game's too quick, here we go.
You ain't got nothin'. Oh!
- [Together] Ahhhh!
- Goalllllllll!
That's one.
- Kobe.
Mamba.
King James.
Ahhh! Ahhh!
Harden, ahhh, dippin, dippin.
Westbrook... boom baby!
- This is not regulation size.
If I get one ball, in one cup, on island,
you drink that cup, plus one of my choice.
Ay, yo, let me get a straight line.
Let me get a play-button.
Let me get a Jesus cross.
Ay, let me get the Hawaiian Islands,
it's where you put six cups,
and you don't make them touch each other.
Elbow! Elbow!
You cannot put your elbow
over the edge of the table.
You didn't pull the cup, I
got the same one as he did,
that's death cup, that's
game over, no rebuttal!
- Ahh man, you know what,
my shoulder dude, ahh!
Is this fluorescent lights in here?
Fluorescent, like my contacts...
I only can do beer pong with lagers,
it's just how it is or else I suck.
It is stuffy in here,
can we put the a/c on?
Ugh, god, the a/c blew my ball!
My girlfriend just broke up with me.
- I never play this game, I
never played this game before.
What!?
Yes!
I'm a natural, what can I say?
Guys, I never play beer pong!
- Alright, good shot.
Okay, alright, really?
- Sneak bounce!
- No, it's not a sneak bounce
if you bounce it every time.
- Every bounce counts.
- Go to your home!
Get out of my house!
I'm a brick wall.
Distraction.
(wailing)
- Alright, yo, let me get a celeb-shot.
Buckets... aww, my bad guys.
Yo, let me get a celeb
- Next time.
- Yo, let me get a celeb shot.
- No, man, same turn, man!
- Yo, can I get a celeb shot?
Alright, yo, after you
guys are done we got next.
Yo, we got next.
So, we got next after she got next,
after she got next, we got next.
Is there even a list?
Hey, we got next.
- I'm in!